did you guys see this Bourbon and Beyond
lineup
the Louisville Festival yes you did Taco
did you see it
I saw it I don't remember what was on it
okay I do know that I saw it okay now
I'm gonna know where you're going yeah
and I thought the other one you sent me
that was it in New Orleans that was an
amazing lineup was that I don't think I
seen anything from New Orleans
let me I just go ahead I don't remember
the bourbon and Beyond Festival I I just
don't recall this being a thing I'm sure
it has been in the past I just it
doesn't Bank in my memory right so isn't
that the one that's out at near the
airport that kind of came up a year or
two ago yeah it may be the Exposition
Center which is a massive so it was it
was it it yeah it had a rough start but
this lineup go ahead and I think I know
where you're going I wanna I wanna go
through one of maybe one of the most
batshit crazy lineups I have ever seen
um especially in the five six years
we've been doing this podcast I don't
know if I've ever seen a a lineup that
goes from Brandy Carlisle and train to
Bruno Mars and Babyface to The Black
Keys and first aid kit to
Brittany Howard
and Wayne Newton yep yeah what talk
about babies oh is that
Duran Duran that's the Beyond section
right it's so crazy I think I'm in love
with it I think I'm absolutely head over
heels in love with this
Wackadoo thing I mean the only thing
that's missing is like puddle of Mud you
know of all the of all of the
concoctions that they could have put
together guys who saw who had on their
bingo card Wayne Newton in 2023
yeah with oh man Mavis they Palo Nutini
haven't heard that name in a good minute
I I just I'm stunned I'm stunned
um and I and I and I had done nothing
but talk about this for weeks now I know
nothing about the festival I know
nothing about the experience but
who is booking this I don't know but I
like them who in the world this is this
is like how me and you guys would get
high one night and just say yeah tell me
this uh who sang this song is Don Ho
available can we do Tiny Bubbles yeah
Dan come in Dan tyminsky's on there you
know the old brother guy Constant Sorrow
I mean it's everybody it literally is I
think you're I think you nailed it it's
like let's get high and see who can
outdo who with the playlist yeah I mean
as soon as I think I have an angle for
this Festival Elaine for it as we talk
about all the time with Brandy Carlisle
and uh Brittany Howard and uh you know
City And Color Old Crow first aid kit as
soon as I see that and then all of a
sudden I see baby face Blondie and Bruno
Mars
that's who I'm going I'm going to see
Wayne look because I'm not going to
Vegas to see him I don't care what
anyone says I don't care what you think
about me I am seeing if I have the
chance to see Wayne
that is nuts absolutely nuts
it's so funny anyway I was I was I was
floored when I saw that and I uh I was
hoping that you had the same feeling as
I did because 100 yeah I mean now I got
Danke Schoen in my head for the rest of
the day
[Music]